O variational quantum eigensolver, ou VQE, é um dos primeiros algoritmos híbridos quântico-clássicos, e é
interessante por várias razões. Primeiro, como veremos neste vídeo, é uma abordagem promissora para alguns tipos de problemas. Em segundo lugar, é importante
historicamente e abriu caminho para muitos algoritmos aprimorados, como o adapt VQE.
E por fim, o VQE é bastante simples. É fácil entender o que os computadores quântico e clássico fazem neste algoritmo
e como eles interagem. Há quatro componentes principais em um cálculo de VQE.
Primeiro, há um operador — geralmente um Hamiltoniano — que chamamos de H, que descreve uma propriedade do sistema que
você deseja otimizar. Outra forma de dizer isso é que você está buscando o autovetor desse operador que
corresponde ao menor autovalor. Frequentemente chamamos esse autovetor de estado fundamental.
Em seguida, há um ansatz — palavra que significa "abordagem". Esse é um circuit quântico que prepara um estado quântico aproximando
o autovetor que você está buscando. Na verdade, o ansatz é uma família de circuits quânticos, porque alguns dos gates no
ansatz são parametrizados. Ou seja, recebem um parâmetro que podemos variar. Essa família de circuits quânticos
pode preparar uma família de estados quânticos aproximando o estado fundamental.
A seguir, precisamos de um estimador — um meio de estimar o valor esperado do operador H sobre o estado quântico variacional atual.
Às vezes o que realmente importa é simplesmente esse valor esperado, que chamamos
de função de custo. Outras vezes nos importa uma função mais complexa que ainda pode ser escrita a partir de
um ou mais valores esperados.
Por fim, precisamos de um otimizador clássico — um algoritmo que varia parâmetros para tentar minimizar essa função de custo.
Vamos descrever o problema que queremos resolver e a abordagem geral antes de tratar como o quântico entra em jogo.
Podemos formular muitos problemas de otimização críticos para a ciência e a indústria como problemas de valor matricial. Comumente, você
quer o menor autovalor da sua matriz e o autovetor que corresponde a ele. A matriz H pode ser
um Hamiltoniano descrevendo a energia de um sistema físico. E o menor autovalor seria a energia do estado fundamental
E0, e o autovetor seria o estado fundamental quântico correspondente, frequentemente denotado ψ sub 0.
Ou a matriz pode descrever uma função de custo complicada associada a problemas de otimização combinatória,
como em logística, e o autoestado s sub ótimo seria uma solução ótima do
problema, como uma string binária rotulando um corte em um grafo de uma rede de distribuição. Na prática,
é comum ouvir o termo Hamiltoniano para todas as matrizes de interesse, mesmo fora das ciências físicas. Digamos que
estamos interessados em uma matriz com n linhas e n colunas. Tais problemas podem ser resolvidos rápida e exatamente usando
solvers clássicos para n de até algumas centenas ou milhares, sem suposições sobre a matriz. Para
matrizes esparsas — aquelas com principalmente zeros como entradas —, isso pode ser muito maior, com n de até um bilhão mesmo em um laptop.
Mas para problemas verdadeiramente enormes que excedem esses números, métodos aproximados ou heurísticos são frequentemente necessários.
Quanto maior a matriz e menos esparsa, menos tratável o problema e mais truques inteligentes devem ser empregados. Suponha que sua matriz seja tão
grande que a diagonalização exata não seja uma opção. Suponha ainda que você sabe o suficiente sobre o seu problema para poder
fazer algumas suposições sobre a estrutura geral do estado alvo e quer explorar estados semelhantes à sua
suposição inicial para ver se seu custo ou energia pode ser reduzido ainda mais. Essa é uma abordagem variacional, e é um método
usado quando a diagonalização exata não é uma opção usando um computador clássico. Funcionaria assim:
Primeiro, você cria um estado de suposição com alguns parâmetros theta que vai variar.
Embora essa suposição inicial possa ser aleatória, isso não é aconselhável. Queremos usar o conhecimento do problema em questão
para adaptar nossa suposição o máximo possível.
Segundo, calcularíamos o valor esperado do operador com o sistema nesse estado.
Terceiro, alteraríamos os parâmetros variacionais e repetiríamos.
Quarto, usaríamos informações acumuladas sobre o espaço de estados possíveis no seu subespaço variacional para fazer suposições cada vez melhores
e nos aproximar do estado alvo.
O princípio variacional garante que nosso estado variacional não pode produzir um autovalor menor que o do
estado fundamental alvo. Então, quanto menor o valor esperado, melhor é nossa aproximação do estado fundamental. Vamos
falar sobre a dificuldade de cada etapa dessa abordagem.
Definir ou atualizar os parâmetros é computacionalmente fácil. A dificuldade está em selecionar parâmetros iniciais fisicamente
úteis e motivados. Usar informações acumuladas de iterações anteriores para atualizar os parâmetros de forma
que você se aproxime do estado fundamental não é trivial. Mas existem algoritmos de otimização clássicos que fazem
isso de forma bastante eficiente. Essa otimização clássica só é cara porque pode exigir muitas
iterações. No pior caso, o número de iterações pode crescer exponencialmente com n.
A etapa única mais cara computacionalmente é quase certamente o valor esperado da sua matriz usando um
dado estado. A matriz n por n deve agir sobre o vetor de n elementos, o que corresponde a operações de multiplicação de ordem n ao quadrado
no pior caso. Isso deve ser feito a cada iteração dos parâmetros. Para matrizes extremamente
grandes, isso tem custo computacional elevado. Agora imagine delegar essa parte do
cálculo a um computador quântico. Em vez de calcular esse valor esperado, você o estima preparando o
estado s de theta no computador quântico usando seu ansatz variacional e depois fazendo medições.
Vamos detalhar isso um pouco. H geralmente não é fácil de medir. Por exemplo, pode ser composto de muitos
operadores de Pauli x, y e z que não comutam.
Mas H pode ser escrito como uma combinação linear de termos H sub alfa, cada um dos quais é facilmente mensurável. Por exemplo,
operadores de Pauli ou grupos de operadores de Pauli que comutam bit a bit. O
valor esperado de H sobre o estado S é a soma ponderada dos valores esperados dos termos constituintes H alfa.
Essa expressão vale para qualquer estado s, mas vamos usá-la especificamente com nosso estado variacional s de theta.
Cada um dos termos h alfa pode ser medido m vezes, produzindo amostras de medição s sub alfa j, com j variando de
1 a m, e retornando um valor esperado e um desvio padrão. Podemos somar
esses termos e propagar os erros pela soma.
Isso não exige multiplicação em larga escala nem nenhum processo que necesariamente cresce como n ao quadrado. Em vez disso,
requer múltiplas medições no computador quântico. Se você não precisar de muitas dessas medições, essa abordagem pode ser
eficiente. E essa é a parte quântica do VQE. Mas vamos falar sobre razões pelas quais isso pode não ser eficiente. Uma razão
para muitas medições é reduzir a incerteza estatística nas suas estimativas para cálculos de precisão muito alta.
Outro motivo é o número de strings de Pauli necessárias para abranger toda a sua matriz. Como matrizes de Pauli mais a
identidade abrangem o espaço de todos os operadores de uma dada dimensão, é garantido
que podemos escrever nossa matriz de interesse como uma soma ponderada de operadores de Pauli, como fizemos antes. Aqui C alfa é um
coeficiente numérico e H alfa é uma string de operadores de Pauli agindo em todos os qubits que descrevem seu sistema.
H alfa teria uma forma assim, onde o n-ésimo operador de Pauli da direita age no n-ésimo qubit. Então podemos
medir nosso operador medindo uma série de operadores de Pauli. Mas não podemos medir todos esses operadores de Pauli
simultaneamente. Operadores de Pauli excluindo a identidade não comutam entre si se estiverem
associados ao mesmo qubit. Por exemplo, podemos medir I Z, IIZ e ZZ
XZ simultaneamente porque podemos medir I e Z simultaneamente para o terceiro
qubit. E podemos conhecer I e X simultaneamente para o primeiro qubit. Mas não podemos
medir todos os Z e ZZ ZX simultaneamente porque Z e X não
comutam e ambos agem no qubit de índice zero.
Então decompomos nossa matriz H em uma soma de Paulis agindo em diferentes qubits.
Alguns elementos dessa soma podem ser medidos todos de uma vez. Chamamos isso de grupo de Paulis que comutam. Dependendo de
quantos termos não comutantes existem, podemos precisar de muitos desses grupos. Chamamos o número desses grupos de Paulis comutantes
de t.
Se t for pequeno, isso pode funcionar bem.
Se h tiver milhões de grupos, isso não será útil. Você registra o valor esperado ou a função de custo
para o conjunto de parâmetros theta usados no seu estado e então atualiza os parâmetros ao longo do tempo. Você pode usar os
valores esperados ou os valores da função de custo que estimou para aproximar um gradiente da sua função de custo no
subespaço de estados amostrados pelo seu ansatz.
Existem otimizadores clássicos baseados em gradiente e sem gradiente. Ambos sofrem de potenciais problemas de treinabilidade, como
múltiplos mínimos locais e grandes regiões do espaço de parâmetros com gradiente próximo de zero, chamadas de barren plateaus.
Então o VQE vai resolver todos os seus problemas mais difíceis? Não. Mas ser melhor em todos os cálculos nunca foi o objetivo. Nós
mudamos o que determina o custo computacional. Veja o que trocamos. Passamos de um processo
cuja complexidade depende apenas da dimensão da matriz para um que depende da precisão necessária e do número de
operadores de Pauli não comutantes que compõem a matriz. Esse último aspecto não tem análogo na computação clássica.
Com base nessas novas dependências, para matrizes esparsas ou matrizes envolvendo poucas strings de Pauli não comutantes, esse
processo pode ser útil. Esse é o caso para sistemas de spins interagentes. Por exemplo, para matrizes densas, pode ser
menos útil. Sabemos, por exemplo, que sistemas químicos frequentemente têm Hamiltonianos que envolvem centenas, milhares, até
milhões de strings de Pauli. Há trabalho interessante sendo feito para reduzir esse número de termos, mas
sistemas químicos podem ser mais adequados para alguns dos outros algoritmos que discutiremos neste curso.
O uso eficaz do VQE também exige que saibamos atributos do nosso estado alvo e possamos selecionar um bom estado inicial fisicamente
motivado, bem como um bom ansatz com relativamente poucos parâmetros variacionais. Isso pode ser
bastante desafiador. O VQE demonstra como os pontos fortes dos computadores clássicos e quânticos podem ser combinados
sem adicionar métodos mais recentes. O VQE não nos ajuda a resolver problemas intratáveis para computadores clássicos, mas
continua a desempenhar um papel no desenvolvimento de algoritmos. E o VQE também nos ensina que transferir uma etapa do computador clássico
para o quântico não é nem melhor nem pior para todos os fins. Em vez disso,
muda quais fatores determinam a eficiência do seu algoritmo. Essa é uma lição geral importante na computação
híbrida clássico-quântica.